we are at the met office headquarters
here in devon this of course is where
those warnings are issued and that red
warning for extreme heat still in place
for today but we have got some news
provisionally the overnight temperature
did break a record last night and we can
chat to annie shuttleworth who is a
meteorologist here at the met office
about that hi annie thanks for joining
us on sky we've got your big wall your
big map here um and we've got some news
about last night haven't we yeah so we
have uh provisionally broken the record
for the warmest night on record uh emily
moore in west yorkshire and you got down
as low as 26 degrees last night so the
previous record was 23.9
so that is smashed it yeah exactly we've
smashed it and we're expecting further
record-breaking temperatures today by
the the daytime as well of course this
is the day isn't it let's just look at
your map where we're looking i mean what
was the highest yesterday we got up to
38. 38.1 degrees yes we got that to that
in suffolk at santander and today we're
looking at highs of 30
of 40 degrees possibly so um 40 in
london and we could possibly reach 41
degree of closer to 41 degrees
across the yorkshire region already so
temperatures are rapidly rising out
there already it's been a very warm
start we've got 28 degrees in london
27 degrees up in yorkshire and also
locally across the north coast of devon
to the lee of high ground and across
west wales as well it's 27 degrees there
as well so it's a very warm start
already and we're going to see a much
hotter a hotter day than yesterday today
amazing to see the variation on the map
here because you've got temperatures of
19 degrees not far outside it's really
amazing by the coastline this of course
down here this screen is what it's all
about in terms of the warnings you've
issued over the last few days and these
are still in place aren't they yeah so
we've had a very hot day yesterday a
warm night last night and today is going
to be even hotter as i said so it's even
more important to take note of these
warnings and take them seriously just as
seriously you would a wind or rain
warning they're enforced all the way
through until this evening we've got
that red warning for more central areas
we're expecting that 39 or 40 degrees
today so take note of those warnings and
make sure you keep out the sunshine keep
drinking water and try and keep as cool
as you can and also look after those who
can't keep themselves cool vulnerable
neighbors or elderly people you may know
okay annie thanks for chatting to us i
know you've got to get back yesterday
was the warm-up day they are saying that
those record temperatures could be
broken and it's today that we're going
to be looking at it but already records
broken that overnight temperature in
west yorkshire smashing previous records